president biden has said he opposes the
death penalty
what is the administration's stance on
tsarnaev
and executions going forward well first
president biden has made clear as he did
on the campaign trail
that he has grave concerns about whether
capital punishment as currently
implemented is consistent with the
values
that are fundamental to our sense of
justice and fairness
he's also expressed his horror at the
events of that day
and his actions uh and tsarnaev's
actions i should say
as vice president he spoke to the people
of boston on the one year and of the
anniversary of the horrible crime
as he said then we are boston we are
america we own
the finish line of course any uh process
uh for um the death penalty policy
moving forward i don't have any updates
on that
as it relates to the specific case i
would refer you to the department of
justice
we saw the statement about the trip but
roberta jacobson and juan gonzalez to
guatemala and mexico are they going to
specifically ask those countries to help
stem the tide of the migrants
uh absolutely part of our objective as
roberta jacobson conveyed ambassador
jacobson when she was in here just a few
weeks ago
was that we need to work and partnership
with these countries to
address the root causes in their
countries to convey clearly
uh and uh systematically that this is
not the time to travel
uh if if i may i wanted to i actually
had a
um a little bit of an update or or just
something i thought would be of interest
to many of you which is
what some of the steps are we're taking
in in these countries to communicate
um and a lot of this is through
of course the state department uh and
embassies uh and
so here's a few things we're doing and
this will obviously increase over time
but just to give you a sense of our
investment
uh the state department continues to we
have we've placed an estimated
17 118 radio ads in brazil
el salvador guatemala and honduras since
january 21st
in spanish portuguese and six indigenous
languages
these ads played on 33 radio stations
reaching an estimated
15 million individuals the part
department has also worked with facebook
and instagram on an advertising campaign
that put out put our migration messages
in the social media streams of millions
of individuals
who fit the profile of intending
migrants these are very targeted of
course
a total of 589 digital ads and paid
search
display and social media supporting the
ongoing migration campaign in northern
triangle countries have reached
more than 26 million people since
inauguration day these ads created over
73 million impressions in the targeted
countries and we're also taking
creative approaches in different
countries uh to make sure we're
we're reaching people meeting people
where they are uh in
in some ways how we try to do things in
the united states so as an example
nbc san salvador oscuro comic book an
animated show seeks to deter
a irregular migration by addressing
violence as a driver
content focused on violent reduction
reach 240
000 young salvadorans in the targeted
audience the two animated episodes
in uh in in this past year have been
viewed by 3.6 million individuals
so each country is taking different
approaches our embassies on the ground
are obviously the experts working with
countries to your point steve
to figure out how to communicate clearly
in
uh languages that are will be received
by the people in these countries
and communicate clearly this is not the
time to come our borders are not open
and we'll continue to pick up this up in
the months weeks and months ahead
so excuse me is there any indication
that this is working that these ads and
all this
whole campaign you're right well first
let me say
it is difficult to note the people who
did not come that that is never a number
we will
have a mark on so this is just part of
our effort
to send a clear message but there's no
question
that funding is needed to address the
root causes in these countries that's
why the president has proposed
funding isn't in his immigration bill
that is
an issue he has worked on in the past
for many years including with
republicans of course to try to
provide funding uh to a number of not
directly to the governments because we
want to avoid corruption in some cases
but to organizations that can help
address the root causes
in these countries so it is not the only
step we're taking but
a number of you have asked very good
questions about specific communications
that we are doing in these countries so
i wanted to venture to provide an update
go ahead
now that the public is seeing some of
the images because the congressional
delegation provided
some photos and descriptions about what
they witnessed
children who are frightened and crying
over crowded conditions
now that the public has seen that is
that not
a crisis and what conditions or
situations what metrics would have to be
in place for the administration
to call us well children are presenting
at our border
who are fleeing violence who are fleeing
prosecution
who are fleeing terrible situations is
not a crisis
we feel that it is our responsibility to
humanely approach this circumstance
and make sure they are treated with uh
treated and put in conditions that are
safe
i will say that um you know these photos
show what we've long been saying which
is that the
these border patrol facilities are not
places made for children
they are not places that we want
children to be staying for a
extended period of time our alternative
is to send children
back on this treacherous journey that is
not
uh in our view the right choice to make
and so
our focus now is on putting in place is
on solutions
and putting in place policies including
uh expediting processing at the border
opening up additional facilities
something that you've seen developments
on over the past several days and
there'll be
certainly more on restarting our central
american minors program which was
stopped in 2017
thousands of kids should be eligible to
apply for that so they're not making
this journey
so our focus is on solutions and
implementing them as quickly as possible
the president said he is open to going
to the border at some point
do you have any sense if during this
current situation he would consider it
valuable to go there
see for himself the conditions talk to
people on the ground is that something
we should expect
i don't have any trips to preview for
you i can tell you that the president is
briefed regularly
on uh situation at the border and every
step that he is pushing his team to take
that his team is taking to uh to put in
place actions to put in place solutions
that will expedite processing
get kids into shelters more quickly uh
and he is uh regularly briefed and but i
don't have any anything to preview for
you on a trip
he also said one of the changes that
could take place is
allowing a process where those seeking
asylum can do it from their home
countries but there are a lot of
advocates who say
that just extends the period of exposure
to poverty violence all of those
conditions
and don't support that so
how is the president uh going to deal
with that
and clearly the border is not closed
given the flow so that seems like a
message that is not
in tune with what people are actually
seeing based on we're now up to
15 16 000 kids in u.s custody and so
forth
well actually the vast majority of
people who come to the border are turned
away
adults families single people who are
coming to the border
are turned away so that is a message we
will continue to convey
through a number of the means i have
outlined for you and uh the president
has also conveyed that directly as has
our secretary of homeland security and
as
uh was noted earlier there's obviously a
trip to the region
as well uh into what sorry was your
first question
frustrated his message isn't getting
through i don't think the president
sees it that way uh the president the
secretary of homeland security um
have all conveyed um that there are a
number of factors at play here
including the fact that a number of the
people who are making this treacherous
journey
are fleeing circumstances that are
difficult on the economic front
to hurricanes gang violence
there are smugglers who are making their
own pushes about how this is the time to
come
so we understand we're working against a
lot of push factors that are pushing
people to come to the region
come to the come to the border but what
we are conveying from our end is that
the border is not open uh the majority
of people are turned away
and we are uh as we're talking about
children here
and with children our focus is on
expediting the processing at the border
and ensuring they can get to shelters as
quickly as possible
thank you jen uh so now that border
patrol agents
in the rio grande valley are letting
adult
migrants go without even issuing notices
to appear
is the immigration policy just becoming
more of like the honor system
that is an inaccurate depiction of
what's happening
at the border so there's no change in
policy the border remains closed
uh families and single adults are being
expelled under title 42 and
should not attempt to cross illegally in
the narrow
narrow circumstances in which families
can't be expelled
the family is tested and quarantined as
needed and placed in immigration
proceedings to commence
in some cases families are placed in
removal proceedings
further along in the release process so
if families are going to be
going to be deported and they're
awaiting uh deportation they don't need
a court date
uh and they don't need a notice to
appear because it has already been
determined that they will be
sent back to their home countries
sometimes that takes a minute
to ensure there is proper transportation
and steps
uh in place to do that but if secretary
my orchestra says the border is secure
the border is closed
how is that the case if these migrants
are being processed on this side of the
border
and then put on a bus to points on
unknown on
this side of the board well again there
are limited cases
where uh there are families uh because
they can't be held in mexico
uh who are uh who are processed tested
considered at the border most of them
are
sent back to their home countries those
are very limited cases and it's
certainly not a depiction of the
overarching policy
okay two years ago president biden said
we are a nation that says you want to
flee
and you're fleeing opposition you should
come
they deserve to be heard that's who we
are now he says
i can say quite clearly don't come over
so why was his position different
campaigning than it is governing
well i think that sometimes there are uh
there are
there's language that is used by some uh
that is not complete
including the full context of his
comments i will say that
he still believes that he wants our
country to be a place where there is
asylum processing at the border
where people are considered and go
through a proper process who are fleeing
prosecution who should be considered
for immigration status that is a process
that is broken
it was broken by the last administration
and he wants to put in place
a process through an immigration bill
through uh steps taken by our department
of homeland security and hhs to improve
that process and make it safe
efficient and effective we're going to
need some time to do that and
the president says that he told us
yesterday i know what's going on in
these facilities you say that he's
been briefed with photos from the inside
i mean he's been briefed
multiple times about immigration and
often has a number of has uh
regular sets of questions for his teams
so what is his concern about this being
a super spreader
event where you've got 400
kids stuffed into a pod built for 260.
these kids are tested if they need to be
quarantined they are quarantined
we also follow cdc guidelines to ensure
that they are kept safe
one of the reasons that it took us some
time to uh
have some of these facilities or some of
the shelters open to
larger groups of kids is because we
wanted to follow those cc
guidelines so we certainly don't see it
through that prism we actually took the
steps we did to keep these kids
but where else in the country would it
be okay to have
400 people in a space for 260 during the
pandemic
well again peter we're closely following
the cdc guidelines that's why we're
opening up additional facilities
why they've been at limited capacity in
a number of these shelters what if i may
i don't know that there are cdc
guidelines that say
you can be open for the sh are you
talking about the shelters are you
talking about the border patrol
apologies i wasn't misunderstanding your
question look i i think our objective
is to move this is one of the reasons
this is such a focus every single day
for the president and this
administration
we want to move these kids as quickly as
possible through these facilities and
into the shelters where they
where there is safe spacing and then
move them into homes where there is safe
spacing
and we are concerned about the public
health impact that's why we're putting
in place a number of policies to
expedite these processes but at that
first stop it's just not
happening and that is part of the
federal government that you guys are in
charge of
well again i think i've outlined for you
specifically even a number of steps that
we have taken and we are taking
to expedite processing at the border to
ensure we're expediting the timeline
because these border patrol facilities
are not made for children
we want to move them in part because of
covid in part because they're not places
that have the educational
the health resources and other resources
that we believe these children should
have access to
that's where all of our focus is on and
why we're working to expedite things we
have a plan
we're implementing it we're confident
we're going to be successful i i we just
have limited time so i just want to go
ahead
a couple questions on the vaccine uh jen
assuming that astrazeneca gets the green
light from the fda what's the
administration's plans for distributing
that vaccine well we don't want to get
ahead of the fda approval process which
i'm sure you certainly understand
and certainly it for any vaccine that's
approved we would integrate it into our
distribution
process um you know equitably is there
the sense that the us would have enough
supply from the other three vaccines
that the astrazeneca
supply could all be shipped overseas
would that be a plan from the
administration i i wouldn't jump to that
conclusion at this point
there are obviously a number of factors
including the fact that
uh these variants are unpredictable
we're still at war with the virus we
don't know which one is going to work
best with children
and so that's one of the reasons the
president and this administration wanted
to be as prepared as possible
and ensure we had a range of options at
our disposal on friday that the plans
were not finalized yet
on sharing vaccines do you have anything
more to update on that no i
you know first we are committed to um
the us has been as you know so you've
covered it closely
one of the hardest hit countries in the
world more than 500 000 people have died
1400 people continue to lose their lives
every single
day as i noted we are there are still a
number of factors that are unpredictable
that we need to
plan for to the best of our ability uh
including the variance
and the impact and what will be most
effective as well as
um what will work best with children uh
we are as as we get increasing
confidence that we have enough vaccine
we will explore options for sharing more
broadly we want to
largely be a part of the global solution
here we recognize fully
that in order to defeat the pandemic
globally
the community the global community
community needs to be vaccinated
but there's a shortage of supply at this
point around the world
but also including around the country
still and
as you know because you all talk to
governors and other elected officials
they are still looking for supply there
are still people who want the vaccine
who don't get the vaccine
uh we are not sitting on a secret dose
of supplies
well we are focused on getting these out
the door as quickly as possible at this
point one more the president on friday
seemed to suggest that he thinks you
could double
the goal 100 million shots in the first
100 days already hit
and he said we hope we can keep the pace
two and a half million a day
may be able to double it is the new goal
now
200 million shots before day one 100 we
don't have a new goal to set our team is
looking at that we certainly want to put
one out
publicly once our health and cova team
has taken a look at
what's viable um and hopefully we'll
have more on that soon
go ahead follow up the meeting over the
weekend
last week with the chinese chinese
delegation in alaska did the president
get what he wanted other than that
meaning does he have any response to
what came from it
and where does it leave the countries
now going forward for instance
is the prospect of some sort of
bilateral meeting
between president biden president xi now
more or less likely
is there anything you can give us on
that well we expected tough and direct
talks with the prc
uh on a wide range of issues and that's
exactly what happened
uh and i know there's been a lot of
focus on some of the
public theatrics or um you know formatic
public peace
but i can assure you from talking to our
national
national security team that it was a
substantive meeting it was a
two-day meeting they covered a range of
issues from
our concerns about human rights abuses
to aggression
in hong kong taiwan our concerns there
economic
our concerns about economic and
intellectual property
and we also of course talk about ways we
can work together so
we're taking stock of where we are this
is where we are now uh i expect the
president will certainly
be talking with his national security uh
team well jake sullivan and and tony
blanken our secretary of state national
security adviser who
traveled uh and we will have close
consultation with allies and partners
on the way forward we'll continue to
work with china of course
uh going forward uh where it's in the
interest of the american people but in
terms of next steps
anchorage was a stand-alone meeting and
we don't have anything more
to determine about what's next and today
the u.s eu and other countries announced
new sanctions on china with respect to
human rights abuses
uh did anything happen that happened in
anchorage
affect that in other words would the u.s
have not participated in that had
certain conditions then that is only
linked between the two
and what next steps do you think china's
retaliate against the eu
do you expect u.s retaliation and is
there any more sanctions you would do if
they don't act
to change course with respect to the
treatment of these minority groups
well on the first question uh i'm not
aware of any linkage or
or plans to pull that back obviously
this was a reaction to
um what we felt were serious human
rights abuses
obviously the europeans felt this as
well against members of xinjiang's
ethnic and religious minority groups and
no meeting would change our concerns
uh related to that and weak action as
you noted uh
in unity with the united kingdom canada
and the european union who also acted
against human rights abusers in
connection with these
atrocities you know this demonstrates
our ongoing commitment to work
multilaterally to advance respect for
human rights
and we continue to have great concerns
about china's crimes against humanity
and genocide on uyghurs
in xinjiang but i don't have anything to
predict for you on future sanctions
obviously this is an issue
that was raised in this meeting last
week and was an issue that was uh
raised by the president in his
conversation
with president g just a few weeks ago
what what will the u.s do if anything if
china doesn't change its approach is
this sort of a one-stop
uh sanction or down the road will this
be revisited and are further sanctions
possible i mean they've given no
indication
that they would change approach in fact
they have more or less double down
because they're doing nothing wrong with
respect to these minorities
well clearly sanctions are meant to
deter behavior but
i'm not going to rule in or rule out any
actions when we're at not even day 60
what are we at 62
i'm not even sure of the administration
uh i can assure you that
um obviously this is
again we will be evaluating what the
appropriate next steps are in close
coordination with our partners
and allies around the world and as
secretary of state noted
uh in his comments after this meeting uh
we
we we are certain that uh the chinese
are noting
that we are working much more closely
with our allies and partners than
had happened over the last four years
that we are focused on taking steps to
invest in and improve our economic
competition here at home
those are all steps we're certain
they're taking note of sorry
guatemala a trip to the president's
proposal
for 4 billion in aid for the northern
triangle has made allusions to
conditions that might be placed on
reforms any corruption effort that sort
of thing
is this something that ambassador
jacobson will raise
at all in other words are you going to
be seeking changes in exchange for any
funding aid funding that might go to the
region during this trip will you specify
any particular asks in that regard um
that's a great question i will also note
that there's also
a part of the part of the trip a
delegation as our new special envoy for
the
northern triangle who i'm certain will
be um playing a prominent role in
leading these efforts and negotiations
moving forward um obviously addressing
issues like corruption violence in the
region and in these countries is
something that is often raised with the
government
uh because we need to work through this
funding mechanism through the
immigration proposal with our own
uh congress i i can't i don't have
anything to kind of
detail for you in terms of what those
conversations will look like but i'm
sure when they come back
we will do a robust readout of their
conversations thank you
go ahead thank you um why hasn't the
administration
sought a supplemental funding to
send resources to the border to to help
the migrant children
um be unaccompanied minors is that
something that's in the offing
well from i know secretary marcus has
spoken to this exact question which is a
great one and
what he has conveyed is that the funding
is not the root issue here
that there are larger issues or issues
that
we have been focused on working through
including
processing identifying additional
facilities that
we think will help address the
challenges we're seeing at the border
okay um on vaccine distribution i know
that there are these two bilateral deals
with mexico and canada i know that you
aren't
ready to talk about lots of vaccine
sharing around the globe but
do you is the administration planning to
emphasize
bilateral agreements on vaccine sharing
globally or
are you expecting to ultimately put
doses into kovacs
we of course remain committed to uh
working through kovacs we provided
uh the most funding to kovacs of any
country in the world with four billion
dollars uh
mexico and canada as you all know our
neighbors and so
it's and there is a great deal of
traffic that can go back and forth
between these countries so
it made sense in those scenarios to do
bilateral uh
lending agreements for lack of a better
phrasing uh
but in terms of future i expect it will
be a combination but certainly we will
continue to be a um contributing uh
supportive member of kovacs
just one follow-up on the tsarnaev
question and
boston bombing um will the president
i guess we're trying to understand why
the department of justice continued to
move forward with this appeal
if president biden's position is that he
has brave concerns about
the death penalty and has president
biden or will president biden talk to
the attorney general about this case
possibly doj consider changing its its
appeal
uh i don't have anything to preview for
you on that front uh the president also
believes that the department of justice
is an independent
institution and of course there are
times where it is appropriate to have
conversations but
i don't have any conversations to
preview for you with the attorney
general thanks
what uh as this previously been
discussed there are some families who
are being released from facilities
into the united states um they're not
being given court dates or paperwork
about how to complete
a legal process how is the
administration going to ensure that they
can follow that legal process that can
be tracked down to make sure that they
show up in court or apply for asylum
are you talking about the limited
families who are um
already in removal proceedings or who
are
it has already been determined that they
are going to be sent back to their
countries or which
there are some there there are very very
limited numbers of families very limited
who are um tested
um they are uh but i'm not sure which
families you're talking about so maybe
tell me a little bit
what numbers are we talking about here
uh it's a great question i'm not
i would just point you to cbp and dhs
for the specific numbers they release
that data and they have it more
at some of these hand
on the border that they're being
released and not being given paperwork
to you know show up and and the migrants
who have spoken to our reporters on the
border are confused about
how to push forward their asylum claims
and how to you know pursue
for two saying somehow i'm not familiar
with the exact case i mean i'm not sure
if this is
one case five cases i'd be happy to
connect you with the
officials there who can um go deeper
dive in
with you okay uh go ahead um so it's
been a year since the u.s mexico border
and the u.s canada border has been
closed
are there any plans and reissuing
guidelines especially with you know the
vaccine distribution
and partnerships we have with canada
i don't have anything to preview for you
it's constantly of course uh reevaluated
we look at it through the
prism of covid and safety and obviously
diplomatic relationships too uh but
i don't have anything to predict for you
on that front go ahead
will secretary austin uh brief the
president on his trip
and secondly the taliban has threatened
the u.s
uh unspecifically about some sort of
action if the us does not meet the may
first
deadline so what is the president's plan
for for that
uh the secretary sees the president on a
several times a week as a partner of the
pdb
uh obviously we don't preview what
topics are discussed but i'm certain he
will
discuss his trip with him given he was
in afghanistan just
over the weekend um in terms of the may
1st
timeline the president spoke to this
during his interview last week with abc
where he
conveyed it would be tough but their
ongoing policy discussions and decisions
right now and i don't have anything to
uh preview for you on that front what is
the president's message tonight for
senate democrats is he going to get into
his his thoughts on the filibuster for
example
uh well he'll take some questions from
them so i'm certain they can ask a range
of a range of topics i think
he certainly wants to convey to them his
gratitude for uh
working with him on the american rescue
plan uh and
can commit to them that he is uh he is
not done yet he has more work to do and
he looks forward to working with them on
continuing to build the economy back
better work to increase
american competitiveness at home uh and
have a conversation with them he'll take
their questions as well what does he
expect to get into the field
naturally i would assume that's going to
come off it may
well we'll see i'm sure if they have
questions about it i'm sure he's happy
to discuss it with them
and then we expect that there's going to
be a number of
judicial nominations coming soon can you
give us an update on that
and secondly when will we hear more
about the bob bauer
uh commission and what will come from
that
uh uh i don't have soon there will be
judicial nominations i don't have a
timeline for you or anything like that
it is something the president remains
committed to on um as
maybe we've talked about in the past i
can't remember he obviously wants
uh it to be representative of uh our
country and
um you know i think that'll be
reflective at the appropriate point in
time
um and then in terms of the judicial um
commission
uh i don't have a timeline on that for
you uh either
go ahead all right two questions
including one from uh people who can't
be here
sure um first of all um it's not the
border
right at the start of the administration
when president signed executive orders
overturning president trump's orders and
so on i mean with hindsight
does he regret not speaking more clearly
and more forcefully saying do not come
to the border
it was a message sent that president
biden's america would be more welcoming
we've been conveying the messages that i
have just conveyed from the beginning
did you have a second question um uh
president uh obama is taking part i
think within the next hour
in an event with protective care talking
about the affordable care act
um uh has has he the question is has he
visited the white house yet or indeed um
although do you know how often he has
spoken to
president biden and are they to take
part in advocacy
at administration events going forward
well
i will say having uh having a unique
view of this
question they are not just they were not
just president vice president they are
friends
and they consult and talk about a range
of issues
and you know i would expect that
continues through the course of
president biden's presidency
that can be done over the phone it turns
out and i don't i think if president
obama had been here you would all know
he's a recognizable figure
but i expect given former president
obama's work on the affordable care act
uh president biden's commitment to
expanding access to
health care uh throughout his presidency
that you know it's an issue they'll talk
about but in terms of
what he'll be involved in i would point
you to his uh team
eric schultz i can give you his phone
number if you need it do you know how
many times they've spoken
since inauguration day i don't have an
exact number for you uh you know they
keep in regular touch and our teams are
in regular touch
um uh about a range of issues um
go in the back thanks jen uh first off
before i get into my other
questions just checking on the president
he uh
fell going up the steps to air force one
on friday is he doing okay
he's a hundred percent fine i don't know
if you've been up those steps they're a
little tricky sometimes
he's doing great
did he see a doctor did he have to see a
doctor over it
um i'm not aware of that being required
there's of course a doctor who travels
with the president
any president of the united states but
um i'm not aware of it needing uh
actual extensive medical attention okay
great
and then on the border of course um no
was it no well i i'm not trying to be
there's a doctor who travels with him
he was walking around as you all saw by
the end of the day so i'm
just trying to be completely transparent
he's absolutely fine uh as he was on
friday
was this weekend he spent the weekend at
camp david he's good
go ahead okay on the border uh you've
said a few times today that the majority
of migrant families are turned away
dhs said last month that number was 42
that's down significantly from say last
october when it was over 90
so what's your threshold for the
majority the majority of people families
everybody who comes to the border of
you look at those overarching numbers is
turned away um dhs is the right
authority for
specific numbers and data on all that
front so i'd certainly
encourage you to keep talking to them so
also you are opening up new facilities
one of the options that's being reported
over the weekend is spending 86 million
dollars on
hotel rooms for some migrants and
feeding them
um how do you square that with
the national guard troops who were
sleeping in parking garages and
you know some of them got sick from
having contaminated food
that's a disparity a lot of people are
pointing out that our national guard was
treated one way
and then illegal immigrants are going to
be put in hotel rooms well
first let me say that um at the time
when we became aware
of the conditions national guard troops
were um
in in in parking garages as you noted
uh the president called the head of the
national guard that day and offered his
assistance offered to
play any role that he could play
boosting morale asking for more aid
making sure they had the right were
treated in the way that they deserved
for the incredible role they've played
so i know that was some time ago but
that was the reaction he took at the
time
one more official levine her
confirmation has gotten a lot of
opposition from republicans specifically
about
the covid nursing home scandal she's
implicated in pennsylvania
for signing a directive on may 18th
while taking her own mother
out of the nursing home there was always
12 000 uh senior deaths that's half
of the deaths cover deaths in
pennsylvania this is the same scandal
that cuomo is facing in new york and the
governor in pennsylvania is under
investigation so why does the
why does your administration feel that
rachel levine should get a pass on this
and get
such a high official position of the
health and human services department
i i have to look into the more specifics
of the detail he's here i don't it does
not sound at all to me like the
similar that her scenario is similar to
uh the scenario in new york but um
we'll follow up with you if we have more
to offer go ahead in the back thank you
um just first to follow up on uh alex's
question
uh about the remarks to the the senate
democratic caucus tonight
is there a reason why the press pool was
allowed
into the remarks to the house democratic
caucus and
that is not the plan for the senate
democrats was that something that
was a white house decision or something
that senator schumer and company
uh decided i'm i'm happy to check on the
access
question i certainly know that you guys
like to have access to these comments or
to the
these events i will check and see what's
possible uh and then
a question on a foreign policy topic
which i i think you're
familiar with through the years uh
senator menendez is leading a group of
uh
senators who are pushing for the white
house to recognize the events
uh of the armenian genocide
as a genocide rather than as a
atrocities of some general form uh
is there any uh update on on the
planning on that
i don't we're certainly aware of senator
menendez's efforts but i don't have any
update on our
our policy go in the back president
biden said yesterday that he regrets
turkey's withdrawal from the istanbul
convention
concerning violence against women is it
to say that he has no capacity to make
the difference
on values with this ally that president
biden has no capacity
certainly we hope that's not the case
turkey is a long-standing
and valued nato ally uh we've shared
interest in countering terrorism
ending the conflict in syria and
deterring malign influence in the region
we seek cooperation with turkey on
common priorities and as with any ally
engage in dialogue to address
disagreements as this was a case in
evidence of
uh okay two more and then i gotta go go
ahead the doctor will empty in the
briefing yeah now
raised a warning the cases are starting
to tick up again of course we're seeing
footage of people outside
big parties et cetera uh governors
within lifting measures
uh are you is the white house is the
president concerned that we're gonna
have a new wave
in the us before vaccinations get in
arms
uh is this a question of the trajectory
we're on or could be on
well i'd certainly um defer to our
health and medical experts including dr
wolinski but i think one of the
messages she has been sending very
consistently as the head of the cdc
is that we need to remain vigilant and
we are not this is not over
we are still at war with the virus
people 1400 people are still dying
every day that requires mask wearing it
requires hand
washing it requires social distancing it
requires getting a vaccine
when you have access and we're going to
use every opportunity to continue to
convey that and
we understand as human beings that uh
people are starting to feel better the
weather's warmer there's toilet paper on
the shelves
whatever it may be but we if we are
going to get to the point of defeating
this virus we need to remain vigilant so
i think it's a reflection of that and i
would certainly defer to them
on any predictions of of the
trajectories
but as you noted we've seen in the data
that we've seen an uptick in some places
and
we wanted to reiterate that we've been
speaking with mayors or governors
asking them to hold off on lifting
restrictions like we've seen in other
places
well jeff science has a weekly call with
governors that takes place
every tuesday the president also engages
with a range of elected officials and
i am certain he will convey exactly that
message uh when he speaks publicly about
this issue again
you said that you were finalizing
details for press access yeah on these
border issues can you commit to that
happening this week
and since the administration the
president's brief
lots of different people at different
staff levels have access to
many kinds of photos can you provide
although we would prefer independent
press coverage can you provide
photos to show public now so we can have
more than relying on the congressional
delegation
well we're working on independent press
coverage we believe that that should
happen and that should be the case and
um i don't pull the levers here um i
wish i was that all powerful i am not
um but i can just reiterate our
commitment to transparency and i
certainly hope to have an update
for you very soon um uh but i can't give
you a deadline
on that and but photos you already have
possession of could be shared with the
public
why not well we're gonna give you access
uh to
the facilities so that the press can
have access themselves
thank you everyone so much
you